foreign
[Music]
my favorite
[Music]
[Music]
night oh
[Music]
[Music]
four to six days later hey what's up
mkbhd here so the transition from all
these intel chips to apple silicon has
been happening throughout apple's lineup
and now we've got the m1 chip in the
macbook air and the mac mini and the
macbook pro and there's also an ipad
with m1 but also now
the newest the most popular desktop
apple makes actually
the new imac so i've been using this
computer and it's been fun but you know
testing is a lot of hard work and
everything but
the more i do the more i'm realizing
that the typical performance testing is
actually not really as necessary with
this i mean this new imac is clearly a
far better computer than the baseline
21.5 inch imac it replaces like that
machine was really starting to show its
age and this m1 version runs circles
around it in every performance metric
imaginable from cpu to gpu
storage capacity and speed it uses less
power it's more efficient i mean it
really is a surprisingly capable and
impressive machine for something that's
just a baseline model really the only
thing that got worse is the port
situation which i'll go over in a bit
but i mean it's essentially the same
computer as the other m1 max and so
it'll perform just like them give or
take a little bit because of thermals
having a fan versus not having a fan but
like if i took uh an m1 mac mini and
glued it to the back of a really nice
display it would perform
just like this one so really what i'm
showing you here is an m1 in a new
outfit
new colorful
really thin
outfit but
this is basically going to be a design
video what we think of the m1 inside
this new design of the 2021 imac now
y'all probably already saw my initial
reactions to the unveiling on twitter i
had plenty of thoughts and i still have
a lot of those thoughts but i actually
wanted to start with this this is
clearly a retro throwback to those
original colorful imacs when they came
out in the 90s back in a time when most
other computers were more of plastic and
beige white towers so this represented a
more approachable accessible new
computer seems like a fun time right now
this nostalgia didn't really hit me
because i wasn't old enough back then to
really be thinking very hard about
computer design but
that's what this again represents it's
an even more friendly accessible
computer design it's what it's supposed
to be and actually even in the way apple
presents it you can see it in their own
materials they're trying to expand even
more on that so this is like the family
computer that's not just tucked away in
an office somewhere but in a family room
or a den or a living room or something
and so to pull that off it's got to be
friendly and accessible and most
importantly to look like it would belong
in any of those rooms so not just like a
metal box but a friendly piece of tech
it's the same challenge that things like
the google home and the homepod have had
now all that being said
it's a mixed bag it's definitely a bit
of a mixed bag for me i honestly just
don't like the way it looks
but it's also clearly not for me and so
maybe it doesn't even really matter if i
like the way it looks or not but let me
just show you let me walk you through
all the things that are new about this
design and then you can decide for
yourself if you're into it or not so
first of all the screen the screen is
bigger and it comes much closer to the
edges than that old imac design so it's
a 23.5 inch 4.5 k display here 500 nits
lcd p3 color it is a very nice display
and honestly if you just start with that
like trying to price out something else
like a mac mini instead with another
nice 24 inch display to try to match
this you're probably gonna lose on price
like this is a great screen but you also
notice pretty quickly this is a very
glossy really reflective display there's
no matte version and you've also got
white bezels
and a pretty huge glossy chin
so if you want a computer that doesn't
have those things maybe you're in a
bright environment with a lot of window
light or maybe you're just not into
white bezels and big chins
then you don't get this imac you should
probably look at another monitor but the
one thing i will say that i've come
around on is at least understanding why
they went with a white bezel
specifically
and it comes back again to that like
friendly face thing so if you're trying
to put this in houses and in people's
rooms a lot of which are in rooms with
white walls and this computer is going
to sit in front of a white wall behind
it
theoretically the white bezels sort of
melt away into the background actually
more than
black bezels would have
right and like i see it i'm not saying i
like it like i'd personally still take
black bezels every single day of the
week but at least we can see what they
were thinking it's kind of the same as
the nest hub or a nest thermostat even
it's trying to be a piece of tech that
can fit into any room and people would
rather have something that looks
friendlier than a metal box fine now the
chin on the other hand this is this is
probably where we're going to start to
disagree i
i get that it's iconic to the imac to
have this chin even though they got rid
of the actual icon the logo but
i just think it would have looked so
much better without the chin so most of
the computer is down there in the bottom
if you look at apple's videos you can
see their basic setup which is the m1
and the logic board and all that most of
the computer down in that chin
then it's just mostly cooling and
speakers throughout the rest so by
shoving the computer down there it let
them make this whole computer
razor thin
11 and a half millimeters thin for the
whole thing it's thinner than a macbook
pro it's thinner than an apple watch
this entire computer
is actually thinner than the depth of a
headphone jack so they had to put the
headphone jack on the side of the
computer otherwise it wouldn't fit at
all
it's stunningly razor thin and it's kind
of amazing that the entire computer fits
inside this sleek case thinner than
pretty much every other 24 inch monitor
and that's all amazing and it clearly
took a lot of work to make it this thin
but after i get it out the box and
decide where i want to put it and
lock it in place
i don't care
i don't care how thin it is so
i'm confident that nearly a hundred
percent of the people buying this
machine would have been totally cool
with it being like
20 millimeters thick
and being able to fit a lot of that
computer stuff behind the display so
that it doesn't have a chin and it would
have looked way better and it still
would have been impressively thin so
then that would have also given them
more room for more impressive speakers
now
it's got some pretty great speakers
already so they're downward firing just
like they were in previous imacs and
they're really much louder than you'd
expect from this small of a frame it can
crank loud enough to fill a room it's
got dolby atmos support and this nice
pretty wide stereo image when you're
sitting right in front of it but there
is a distinct lack of deep bass which
makes perfect sense it's just built-in
speakers and an all-in-one but it's it's
so thin i bet if it was thicker you
would have had some more space for maybe
some more basic speakers they also
probably could have fit the power
adapter inside the computer like with
all the rest of their desktops but they
really leaned into
the external power brick situation with
the imac here there's an external power
brick here that's pretty beefy but
they've made the most of it they've got
color matching cables and there's
magnetic pins into the back and they've
also built in an ethernet port into the
brick in the higher end models which is
super convenient since it saves you yet
another cable sticking out of the
computer itself all that being said
the way i feel is they should have made
it a little thicker and nixed the chin
but that's just me maybe let me know
what you think in the comments below but
they went with the chin so it's here
keep using it for your your post-it
notes keep keep using it as a as a
little handle for your not height
adjustable stance just for pivoting but
it is what it is it's here now as an
all-in-one the imac is pretty much the
gold standard for built-in accessories
and components so i was looking forward
to the webcam and mic for this one and
they're pretty good actually better than
i was expecting it is 1080p finally
which is awesome but more than that the
colors and the contrast are way better
actually better than i feel like they
were in the m1 laptops and the studio
quality microphones as you can hear best
mics ever in a mac
are pretty good they're pretty useful
they they focus on your voice so if
you're further away from the mac it can
still hear you like this all right but
let's talk about the port situation real
quick so this is probably the only
little red flag or downside of this new
generation so the baseline imac starts
at 12.99
and that's that's the baseline so it's
the cheapest one but that particular one
has almost no ports that desktop has a
headphone jack and two thunderbolt usb c
ports
no ethernet on the power brick no sd
card slot like that is it that's a wired
mouse and a keyboard and you're already
out of ports
but if you upgrade to the higher spec
models that start at 14.99 then you have
two more usbc ports for a total of four
but yeah no hdmi no usba
just usb-c here no matter which model
you get it's just it's worth noting so
if you're if you know you're going to be
plugging in external storage or one or
two things right off the bat a card
reader you're going to be running out of
ports pretty quick but then again let's
be real most of the people getting these
machines are going to use apple's nice
beautiful colorful new uh accessories
that are all bluetooth and it was funny
during the unboxing seeing matching
piece after matching piece it just kind
of struck me how well thought out all
this stuff is so with the blue imac the
power cable is blue the lightning cable
for charging anything lightning is blue
there's a new track pad and magic mouse
neither of which are redesigned at all
just blue now instead of silver and
there's also even dual tone blue
stickers in here to match that computer
and then there's a new magic keyboard
with touch id which is super dope very
useful especially if you're used to
other laptops they've made i'm pretty
sure it's literally just an old iphone's
touch id button like cut out into the
center of a keyboard key because that's
exactly what it looks and feels like but
hey it works as advertised for logging
in switching between users authorizing
payments all that one thing i've noticed
is it is a little bit slow
and i figure maybe that's because it's
sending information encrypted over
bluetooth to the imac and back but
that's a fine sacrifice for me but also
this new keyboard with the base model
doesn't have touch id so that's another
cut for the base model imac along with
one gpu core an ethernet port and two
usb-c ports but overall even though i am
someone who's obviously not in the
target demographic of this baseline imac
i actually think it's a great computer
it is a really good computer i just
think you should be wary of the baseline
situation because that's almost
guaranteed less ports than the computer
you're currently using um so check that
out just make sure you have the right
port situation if you upgrade you get
ethernet you get two more ports you get
another gpu core you can get more
storage but
just as far as the computer that this is
replacing it's miles ahead of that old
21.5 inch imac honestly the only reason
you might go with a mac mini
and another monitor is if you really
don't like the design at all or if you
just hate a glossy display or if you
want some sort of a different style if
you can't stand white bezels if there's
something else to it
then you can shop around but again
you're probably gonna have a hard time
finding a monitor this good
in a package like this so that's the
appeal of the imac but now i get to get
even more excited about the next steps
in the apple silicon transition m1 has
been
amazing so far
but i am so curious about what they're
gonna do with the big macbook pro with
the imac pro maybe it won't have a chin
maybe they'll go crazy with an apple
silicon mac pro i'm just i'm ready to
see the rest of that lineup but until
then m1 stuff is out
let me know what you think of this
design in the comments section below i'm
super curious to hear what you think but
until the next one thanks for watching
catch you guys later
peace
you